sort of full-blown crying oh my God I'm
gay Renee Rapp opens up about her
sexuality and dishes on her first girl
crush I feel like I should just like
feel the feelings the sex lives of
college girls star is bisexual in real
life and plays a lesbian on the show
Don't Cry he's not worth it
it wasn't a guy it was a girl I'm gay
now Renee is getting candid on the
latest episode of the call her daddy
podcast about the first time she had
feelings for a woman when I was 14 I
like was doing a musical
and this girl who is the lead she's she
had like red like spiky hair and like
she never wore a bra I was just like so
intrigued by her but I was like I can't
I I cannot I cannot stop looking at this
girl's boobs like like that was the
moment that I was like oh my God I'm gay
Renee says growing up in North Carolina
she only knew one other person who was
bisexual a family member whom she looked
up to but according to Renee her family
didn't really understand and thought you
could only be gay or straight I was like
well gotta pick a side have to be a
lesbian so I decided
that I would call my friend at the time
and I was like hey I just want to let
you know
um
I'm gay she was like okay so do you
think you like don't like boys at all
and I was like no no no I still do I
still do but I'm I'm a lesbian though
she was like I think you're bisexual I
was like now Renee owns her sexuality
and is comfortable in her skin much like
her character Layton on the HBO Max
series
I'm in my like sleigh era right now are
you happy in terms of
who I am and my sexuality
yes
yes I am I think for Leighton there's a
there's like such a
huge sigh of relief figuring out who you
are being okay with that and accepting
that I feel like my genuine like coming
out to my family
close and extended has been doing
college girls now I'm like on a TV show
and I'm like very publicly like out and
accepted
as a bisexual woman and everybody's like
yeah oh my God amazing I did not have
that same support as a kid and all that
Echoes what Renee told E.T last year
reflecting on what the show means to her
I think for me the show is cool to now
be doing it 22 when like I was going
through the like 18 and now a
little bit more so it means a lot yeah
now it's safe to say Renee has a lot to
celebrate this is what I've dreamed of
doing my whole life both at the same
time season three of sex lives of
college girls is in the works and she
dropped her debut album everything to
everyone in November
[Music]
every
now she's set to star in the Mean Girls
musical movie as Regina George
I really want to lose three pounds
oh my God what are you talking about
you're so skinny shut up it's a role she
previously played on Broadway and
recently she opened up to ET about
bringing the character back this time
for the big screen well we're cooking is
like
gonna be a very exciting authentic take
on like what Mean Girls is and what Mean
Girls was to us as kids Mean Girls was
such a big part of my childhood so now
I'm like oh this is what this meant to
like me and my generation and it's a
huge impact
[Music]
thank you